When we spoke earlier today, you said to take zinc and vitamin C to help reduce my high copper levels, do I take them at the same time or do I take one person the other later? No, I said those in your package today, so you don't need to order my through bottles of both those in there that got shipped out with that ball today, so you don't have to worry about ordering them. Take them at the same time.
So take the zinc and a teaspoon of the I gave you the light was on the vitamin C and the bottle of clear zinc, I would do three a day.
The zinc and the vitamin C do watch like I said, so a person that has copper toxicity, which a lot of people do.
Very comfortable.
A person that has copper toxicity, if you start taking zinc, because that's what you would help, that's what you take to pull the copper out of your body, you could actually feel sick, because zinc will grab copper out of the tissues, but it ends up dumping into the blood and you could end up with technically, like a herc side of her type reaction, so you could feel ill, you could feel like fluids, you could feel sluggish, you could get headaches.
But if you take the vitamin C with the zinc, and it can be just a squirmic acid that you have at home, but I had some like was able vitamin C, so I gave it to this person, which is even better, but taking this vitamin C with the zinc helps grab on to the copper helps it pull pull it out of the mind.
So I'm not a fan of using copper and supplements, there are whole food supplements that have copper that's naturally occurred, there's no getting around that.
But any supplements that add copper to them, especially in doses that exceed the daily limit of copper, you're getting copper in your vegetables, it's not like we don't need copper, it's just that we get too much copper.
And even copper that we're exposed to as a child, let's say you lived in a house and in copper pipes, which like probably 60 70% of the homes in America have copper cloney.
A lot of people use copper cookware, a lot of people have used those copper bands copper does absorb through the skin.
It was very popular, you know, a couple years back to use copper for people who have arthritis, it's really helpful, no, it's not excess copper is really dangerous.
So and copper for cancer is even worse because copper helps stimulate growth and we don't want that, but excess copper, whether you're a cancer or not can lead to what's called copper toxicity and can push out.
So the zinc levels, and you really need to stimulate it and be in response to help kill cancer.